hey brady we are going to talk about
euclid's fifth axiom the parallel
posture really what this axiom is about
is
a story of a revolution about two
thousand years in the making so the
axioms are there are five and the axioms
are about geometry so geometrical
figures okay let's start with um let's
start with number one let the following
be postulated okay one
to draw a straight line from any point
to any point we have points and lines
and we can connect
between two points we can connect the
points with a line
all right that's pretty simple all right
what's next okay number two to produce a
finite straight line continuously in a
straight line so this might seem
a little unclear what's happening is
that we're creating um
a plane think of a line segment that's a
finite straight line and we're going to
continuously move it in a straight line
that gives breath so we have from a line
to moving in a line we get a plane now
we've talked about points and lines and
we've created a plane we can move to um
circles
to produce a circle
with any center that's a point
and any distance
or radius we've gone from points and
lines and planes to um
now
allowing some other objects to live in
our our world circles the first three
seem straightforward enough number four
things start to get slippery number four
is that all right angles are equal to
one another
well that's gotta be the most obvious of
all of them
why do we even need to say that what a
right angle is requires definition and
euclid actually starts by defining what
points and lines and these basic objects
are but the notion of equality is more
subtle because do we mean equal in the
sense of is
oh
this is exactly the same as that or a
notion of congruence we got four
now we're coming to the fifth this is
this is the one that we should be paying
attention
that's right so here comes the fifth uh
the fifth possible let's write it down
um the way you euclid wrote it and then
we'll
decide for ourselves what it means that
if a straight line falling on two
straight lines makes their interior
angles uh on the same side stay with me
uh less than two right angles then the
two lines if produced indefinitely meet
on the the side which are the angles uh
the angles less than two right angles
it's not catchy isn't it
there's a lot of words wordy and
let's see what it means two straight
lines for instance we're going to put a
third one in
which lies on top
now
the the wordy bit about the uh
interior angles being less than um
two right angles all those interior
angles there
and then
the
axiom says it is if these two lines are
extended then there will be a point
where they meet ah so if if these aren't
90 they're going to crash
that's right
an equivalent way of saying this um this
statement is the following so if you
have a line
and a point not on that line just say
here then there exists a one and only
one line through this point
parallel to the given line any other
line
that we we draw
will eventually intersect the given line
so immediately um this stands out this
axiom stands out from the others and and
it's just
in his wordiness and and the fact that
um it's not completely straightforward
he was kind of uh aware of this and that
he used it reluctantly and even in
the analysis of deducing uh other
propositions in in the elements he was
to use this axiom as long as possible
it's his axiom of last resort
yes
and and
although when we
write it down we
we can think this is a
we can understand why you take it as an
accident and we it seems very
straightforward and so here's the
amazing story the 2 000 year old uh
story of um this revolution this
revolution idea the fifth turns out to
have um
this kind of departure into
other worlds
the first two had to deal with them
lines points and planes and the third
had to do with the circles number four
is is also there's some more hidden
things there but the fifth this notion
of parallelism
is is turns out to be the key in kind of
unlocking
new and mysterious worlds in um 18 20
1830 um independently
two mathematicians a hungarian
bulai and a russian lobochesky they
independently discovered what we now
call hyperbolic geometry and the fifth
axiom so we can write maybe five prime
can be stated like this given any um any
line and a point not on
that line there exists infinitely many
straight lines through that point
parallel to the given line so parallel
meaning
not
intersecting a moment ago we drew
something that showed there was only one
parallel iron now you're saying they're
infinite
that's right where can these be drawn
what does this what does this look like
so
this new world is the hyperbolic plane
which they've created well i actually
said out of nothing i have created an
entire world so now it turns out that
straight lines in the hyperbolic plane
in this model of the hyperbolic plane
look like this well euclidean vertical
lines that intersect this
boundary at 90 degrees or um euclidean
circles centered
on the uh real line so centered at the
real line means that we would intersect
at 90 degrees
so these are straight lines
in hyperbolic space so that's a straight
line too in a hyperbolic plane that's
right
it doesn't look like it is but it is
okay so let's take um
this is our given straight line
and let's take this point as the point
not on the straight line
so we've drawn one straight line
um parallel to the given one
and parallel in that they don't
intersect
but now
so that line is parallel to that line
yes that's right uh we see parallel
lines are lines that don't intersect
so they don't intersect with our
hyperbolic eyes or the hyperbolic metric
these lines are indeed straight and they
don't intersect so they're parallel and
now through this point we can draw
another
straight line it's parallel to this and
we can draw
another so all these circles are
perpendicular to the boundary
and going through this point
uh it's an unfamiliar thing to most
people and it certainly
behaves quite differently than euclidean
space so at first it's confusing but i
think
you can get used to it fairly quickly if
you think about it